today congressman andy biggs made that
point he was then interrupted by our own
greta thunderberg
the creepy little publicity seeker david
hogg remember him watch this
it's purposeful on the part of the
federal government which is basically
sanctioned this invasion
and it's purposeful
iterating the points of mass shooters in
your manifesto the shooter in my high
school anti-semitic anti-black and
racist the shooter in el paso described
it as an invasion guess what those guns
are coming from the united states of
america they aren't coming from mexico
they
are
not coming from mexico you are
reiterating the points of a mass shooter
sir sir you are perpetuating this
violence
so you got the low iq harvard students
screaming about race racers
another self-righteous child who has no
idea what he's talking about
but david hogg appropriately named
character obstructed an official
congressional proceeding wow that sounds
like insurrection
liz cheney was cheney isn't that a crime
is this insurrection it's going to face
charges liz cheney
well andy biggs is the member of
congress whose official business was
interrupted by this insurrection she
represents arizona in the us congress he
joins us tonight congressman thanks so
much for coming on so
i found it interesting that rather i
mean you were making you know people
could disagree with the point you were
making but it was kind of a logical one
he didn't respond to a single point and
just start screaming about racism
am i missing something is that what it
was
yeah that's exactly what it was i mean
he's saying that i'm a a terrorist
manifesto
toten conspiracy nut and the reality is
he's he's all he was he wants to get on
tv and he wanted to advocate for a nutty
position and he right
as number of us
raised he interrupted our proceeding and
democrats have said if you interrupt a
congressional proceeding that's the
definition of insurrection and so the
police had to take him out
um he was invited there by the democrats
that's what i'm informed and so he's
trying to grift on this whole thing it
looks like
and uh he
he should probably be brought up in
charges where is that j6 committee when
you need him that kid and i know a lot
of your colleagues went to harvard and a
lot of americans still think it's
impressive
at some point knowing that kid got into
harvard can we just all admit it's
actually kind of a mediocre joke or no
yeah absolutely
harvard harvard has gone the way of the
of all the woke post-secondary
institutions in the country there's very
few of them that aren't going to turn
out somebody who's as radical as that
and uh you know stoking the fire like
that is what the democrats did that's
why they wanted him there they were they
were hoping for that kind of incident
i think that kid's too dumb to host a
cable news show and that's saying a lot
because he picks intact after his
meeting with david hogg great to see you
we'll be right back thanks
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight